the night coming forward as Magnus plays  now I think not just is it strong but  it's also got psychological uh I mean  it's it's going to be a blow to Wesley  it looks like it wasn't possible but he  plays it sacrificing a knight remember  if it's captured quintix porn hitting  the Rook the threat needs to come back  with a deadly check  looking good  and the evaluation bar shows it is still  very strong for white  less patient but more direct  matter of taste as you say yeah  and uh yeah Magnus putting pressure on  this one it feels like Wesley's been on  the back foot for move one or as soon as  we've joined the game uh essentially  down to three in a bit minutes and it's  only moved 24. Wesley  up against the clock and up against  Magnus who's in the Rhythm who's really  upping the ante  yeah and there you see Magnus focusing  hard and a critical move on the board  for Wesley so I just like that image of  both of those